thank you
[Music]
so father and son in the UK they're
doing home renovations
they start redoing the floor they found
something they get under the floorboards
and all they find is this singular
photograph
what what place what city location UK
that's a big country ugh just kidding
it's pretty small here's the photo they
found
[Music]
others it's a ghost it's a ghost in the
background bro anything uh yeah there's
a faded guy in the back yeah who's the
guy in the middle that's weird and maybe
maybe they dropped like a little bit of
water on it that's that's true
am I wrong or maybe it's a maybe it's a
grandpa ghost sure they said it
apparently it looks like it could be
from the 1960s so it's not like super
old yeah but it's still creepy out but
there's a creepy thing with there's like
a guy in a suit between these people
that looks like he's from the 1900s yeah
why would they put it in the under the
carpet
that's weird I got chills dude you got
chills It's Just an Illusion that it the
the photo was taken a weird way and then
it just popped up and then it just so
happens to look like a guy said it could
be a number of things it could just be a
double exposed photo because that was
kind of or maybe a Photoshop yeah yeah
maybe when they're making the carpet
like they were covering the carpet the
photo did one of these fly down and went
under the carpet and then they got stuck
there or it could have been two photos
that were pressed like this for a while
you know what it looks like um it looks
like the family is standing outside of
like a retail window yeah and as if that
guy in the suit is like a mannequin in
that window oh like a reflection yeah it
looks like they're they're in front of a
glass thing but you know who gives a
[ __ ] about logic we want to know the
ghost story about yeah what's the ghost
yeah tell me the beaky blind or ghost
stories they didn't really know thing
it's they're kind of leaving off the
internet to decide dude I bet there's a
lot what was that I bet there's a lot of
ghosts there because they're like their
buildings be like older than some of our
[ __ ] ancient [ __ ] yeah I mean if if
that's what makes ghosts exist that
would be a good place I think Oxford
University is as old as like [ __ ]
Mayan temples and [ __ ] or something like
or Aztec temples or something really
cool yeah well like the some of the
temples
aren't that old but they look like
thousands of years old and in Central
America Giza Pyramid same age
it was like Central America
yeah like some of those some of those
pyramids are the same but they they just
look [ __ ] old as [ __ ] they say that
in the teacher's lounge there's a
pharaoh buried in the Oxford University
it's that old that's crazy this guy got
the uh like muskoosie yeah
a little stereotypical mustache yeah but
here's the thing some people are saying
I couldn't see it but some people are
saying they see a monk in the doorway
whoa It's just dirty screen the first
time I swear everything too can I see it
can I see it up close I don't yeah put
that in right in his face
they say they see a monk in the doorway
and also a horse's head on the guy on
the left's like chest so uh
I'm not afraid of course I I'm sure that
I will feel uh fear Feel the fear if
there was a ghost present but I think
the idea of it is really exciting and
fun to me yeah I would love to like all
of us I'd love to be together yeah right
all of us like ran into a gus we had to
[ __ ] go on some like College Tour
trip and present as JK or whatever the
[ __ ] and then there was a ghost in one
of our rooms that [ __ ] would be fun as
[ __ ] I think we should do and JK ghost
adventure because we're already doing
the adventure stuff we need to bring
Hannah she could see him why because
she's you can she can see them really my
mom could see them yeah she could see
them so we we get your mom and have to
feel them and then we get them to write
down what they see and if it doesn't
match they're both full of [ __ ]
so the thing is there's so many people
that I heard that have seen [ __ ] whether
it's in their mind or their mind's eye
or whatever it's like
I feel like they have to be shown it you
know what I mean it just doesn't come
out of nowhere or are they just like
hallucinating what do you think Hannah
says you've been seeing them since kids
yeah because I always hear stories like
that where people say yeah you know
sometimes you just see people out there
and then next thing you know they're not
there she Point them out to me like we
were driving by
um this like housing projects and she
goes oh there's some ghosts right there
by that door some goes yeah and then she
said that when we were at I the Luxor
you just got me scared uh uh the this
guy was watching us
what yeah this guy was watching us in
our hotel room maybe we just don't go
with Hannah bro for the first one just
for the first one and then after we get
our feet wet then we could go and Hannah
because I think she's gonna bring some
real ghosts bro dude so my mom uh did I
tell you guys the story about how uh I
lived in one of these houses in OC where
uh my mom saw like a spirit in the
backyard and or when you guys were
raising chickens no different different
house actually yeah it was that house oh
it was on uh in Anaheim and so basically
when we moved there which was like what
five years ago uh she said she could
send something and at some point she saw
like kids and then she didn't know why
right and so they had
um I guess like a priest come and bless
the house or whatever and then she also
talked to the landlord and he was saying
oh yeah uh there used to be a pool here
and apparently like a kid drowned there
oh my God and but she saw it before she
even knew that and so so she was she
could like send stuff like that she
could feel it like
yeah on her neck and then
um just recently in the house that I'm
at now
um she said she saw a little girl in the
backyard and it was because my dad kept
putting out like offerings like fruit
and whatever and lighting incense and
stuff so that lingering Spirit or
whatever is just like trying to get that
food and that's that's what my mom was
saying but isn't that also like
I think there was a child here before
and it's like within the last 300 years
probably a kid though right right I got
my favorite yeah specific but it's very
specific though because she saw two kids
and it was two kids that died it's like
something like that but
um at first I was like well I can't see
him so I don't believe it but then it's
like well what if she actually does see
them but we can't and then it's like
maybe they could just see like uh a
different plane of existence but but if
Jason can they go close no why would
they
because just to make sure that they
actually
yeah why do you say why would they you
know yeah well you could definitely see
maybe I don't know maybe because they do
one of these because she's seen them so
many times it's like she doesn't want to
mess with it but I think we need to have
all the ghosts ears in together and they
need to go together to these haunted
places and be like do you see it do you
see it I think that's such a brilliant
idea that they can't they have to
describe the same thing that they say in
different rooms they can't be together
it's like the kids that clearly couldn't
see the Magic Eye [ __ ] but they [ __ ]
[ __ ] like they do yeah oh a boat and
in your life oh I see it and then the
kids be like yeah I see it too they're
like oh really then what's inside
they're like well tell you tell me first
dude
you're gonna see the Magic Eye [ __ ] it's
a Magic Eye Turtle you tell me first
those things too once you start putting
science to it and trying to do it as an
experiment it's not gonna just happen
yeah because the ghost goes oh science I
don't want to [ __ ] be here
holy water that's the problem with most
forms but if you try to break it down I
think what if what if it they do both
see the same ghosts like like yeah like
let's say it is real how do you explain
it then you're buying it right I think I
think we all see the same ghost then I'm
like what's going on the easiest thing
is just to like get on the [ __ ]
police radio go to whatever site where a
kid freshly died and then we hang out
there and go what's this kid Mexican
Chinese you have all the data you let us
know why isn't there like a ghost
like I like I see Ghost Community like
there's other communities right that's
like probably is yo like do you see this
[ __ ] or like whatever right and then
they can go out and do ghost hunting
together like they're training just to
make sure it's like nope it was an
orange shirt yeah not fuchsia see yeah
but there's also people that can't
really see them but they could sense
them too well that's what can be they're
like the wasted ones that's what can be
a problem when they have those ghost
detectives that like got so famous and
they started using them for real crimes
and then they were like you know your
daughter died and then it turns out she
was [ __ ] alive and they stopped
looking you know that [ __ ] happens too
yeah like the animal people
from the movie wasn't that kind of
almost based off of uh I mean I'm
talking about real ones like those
psychic psychic detectives right yeah
yeah there's real ones that have said
the complete opposite or there's real
ones that have made families not stop
looking and then the [ __ ] actual
Corner comes back and goes hey we found
the bones like they're dead like but
then she's like I see her in a van in
Nebraska oh there's definitely ponies
too yeah but psychic detectives I think
that's a slippery slope because there's
you're monetizing it at that point right
and then at that point there's a
different
um motive but if we go to a haunted area
together you know I think it's and we
all see the same [ __ ] together I think
that's pretty cool I don't like how
every single time it's different too
though they'll be like that's not how it
works and it's like it's never
consistent right there's no governing
rule they need to have a ghost community
and I I want the the most powerful ghost
years to get together and then it's kind
of like karate like you got the master
that's true that can always see them and
then all the way down to The Feelers The
Feelers are the ones like I know there's
a ghost here but I don't even know what
the [ __ ] is going on and then the more
powerful you are you're like a wizard
you're like the grand wizard that
understands it all you're like the
Merlin of the ghost world and I want to
see them like be out in the open because
right now all I see are some fake ass
[ __ ] yeah that's true it is
fake until like what if one day you're
the one that sees it and you're and then
nobody believes you well then you better
find it good I'm gonna be mad at myself
because I can't I can't figure this out
I'd be so frustrated I'd be like what
the [ __ ] man how come I could only see
it once in a while it's like a fart you
can't really control it and for those
that can their Master because it's
metaphysical it's not on this like plane
of existence it's completely different
what about some people that just see
stuff that's really not there if it's
just deeply cognitive what if you're
schizophrenic yeah yeah what about that
yeah I'm sure how do you tell the diff
or just like an idiot yeah without I
think it's always it's all good with
that thing like if you just have the too
powerful person be like is it [ __ ]
third red shirt yeah and then if the
person you said blue yeah you said blue
they corroborate in the back all right
I'm gonna say red shirt you say red
shirt okay
can you explain when like so many people
on this Earth have the same experience
like ghost experience when they're not
even from the same like you know like
can you give us an example like for
example there's like uh cultures in Asia
where they see they see their own
spirits and then in the west they also
see ghosts like how come everywhere in
the world experience this whole ghost
thing or is it just all I think the
discrepancy is in the confirmation I
think if you get all these people
together and you they know that they
want to relate and have the same
experience story they will adjust their
stuff because humans love shared
experience because I think people will
go me too like knowing that it's not
exactly specific I have to write it in a
sheet of paper do what I mean yeah red
shirt and then this person is like blue
shirt
and then they're like no not me too do
we all agree it was purple now yeah yeah
yeah it could have been perfect
[ __ ] yeah I think there's a little bit
of that too that's why it'll you'll
never really know because when it comes
down to hard proof it's it's like a
James Randy like all the times that he
tested psychics or people with ESP they
all said the same thing it doesn't work
if you're watching it doesn't work if
you're looking yeah what are these rules
you don't they don't that but they're
all con artists we've yet to see a guy
just [ __ ] show up and fly into the
air and just go I can [ __ ] fly you
idiots yeah like that'll you know David
Blaine monetizing it but if the ones
that aren't monetizing it why aren't
there evil psychics why aren't there
evil monetizing ghost Sears like why
aren't there evil ones how come they're
all good I believe ghosts exists but I
feel like there's a group of people that
[ __ ] take it too far and those are
the people that ruin it for everybody
and those are the guys like Ghostbusters
but that's that's the funny thing is
like if innately most humans tend to be
evil when given a form of power why why
are almost 100 of people that can see
ghosts not using it for evil
um and why does it why do they have a
convenient reason that's always not
um confirming like you can't confirm
their reason like it's very much always
changing depending on how they want it
to be or is it different it's like when
we talk about the word ghosts you think
about those people but then when we
don't call them ghosts and call them I
don't know the devil suddenly there are
evil people that are seeing those
Spirits no yeah that's true but they're
not using it for things like winning the
lotto and going like hey I won the lotto
50 times because I could see this
winning the lotto is not evil you know
what I mean I do feel like whatever
these phenomenons are when we have the
right tools to figure out what's
happening like it could be some in in
someone's brain frequency like they
imagine certain things it could be
something that's more like
um like energy or some [ __ ] yeah like
what do you call that it's like physics
where uh quantum physics or like it's
time stacked upon each other and
everything is happening and it's like a
glitch yeah yeah could be scientific in
that sense it could be a simulation
Theory where like there's other you know
like things that we can't see that's
working behind the scenes you know yeah
plus every single time we see like a
spirit or a ghost or something that's
caught on camera those cameras are
always like 360p it's yeah why is it
never 4K 4K yeah yeah the [ __ ] it's
almost pixelated too much data dude I'm
just wondering you know yeah it's really
inconvenient something to think about I
would I would love to have an
opportunity to see something when I
don't have to meet it halfway I would
love that
foreign